hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts cannabis impact on pain
and opiate use a clinicians perspective
presented by dr. Kent Crowley director
of research and product development
silver state treating I am Kay lee baca
laggards and i will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by walkers labs is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
question and hit set well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located on promotional Ford at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem please join me
in welcoming dr. Crowley I will now turn
the presentation over to him it is a
pleasure to get to present to you on
this topic I have been working in pain
management for most of my professional
career which started following my
graduation from UCSF in 1983 with my
doctor pharmacy degree it has been less
than five years since I added cannabis
as a treatment modality and the
management of pain to my functional
medicine practice during this talk I
hope to share my insight into how we
have arrived to this point in time and
offer solutions to the use of cannabis
in the management of pain the learning
objectives are to review the current
status of the opioid crisis in the
United States to explore the results of
a recent study examining cannabis as a
treatment for non-cancer pain identify
approaches to use standardized formulas
to
/ cannabis in a reliable way and discuss
the implications of adding cannabis to
management pain management strategy the
New York Times reported January of 2017
that public health officials have called
the current opioid epidemic the worst
drug crisis in American history
killing more than 33,000 people in 2015
The Washington Post reported August of
17 that more than 142 Americans die each
day of drug overdoses in an estimated
two to three million people are hooked
on prescription painkillers or heroin
according to the American Society of
addiction medicine this is a picture of
discarded needles on April 10th of 2017
at a heroin encampment in Philadelphia
in a recent report from the CDC in
August of 17 the number of overdose
deaths involving opioids in 2016 than
include both prescription opioids and
heroin was five times higher than in
1999 from 2000 to 2016 more than 600,000
people have died from drug overdoses on
average a hundred and fifteen American's
die every day from an opioid overdose
now just to put this into perspective
the leading cause of death in the u.s.
is heart disease and that claimed the
lives of more than five hundred and
twenty-five thousand men and women in
2016 this map looking a bit confusing
portrays the you
yes counties within given States for a
given year from 2006 through 2016 here's
a different look at that data going from
1999 to 2016 identifying at the 2016
point of forty two thousand two hundred
and forty nine recorded US opioid
overdose deaths more than any year on
record
40% of all opioid overdose deaths
include a prescription opioid what drugs
are contributing to this crisis opioids
are a class of drugs derived from the
opium poppy plant that can be divided
into two broad categories legally
manufactured medications and illicit
narcotics because of supply limitations
of prescription opioids people in the
last few years have increasingly turned
to synthetic opioids as such as fentanyl
in its derivatives because of the low
cost in easy access the problem of these
synthetic opiates can be more than a
hundred times more potent than morphine
in March of 16 the CDC issued
restrictive guidelines to primary care
physicians treating patients with
chronic non-cancer pain even before
these guidelines were published Congress
made the guidelines mandatory for the VA
this new standard placed a maximum
amount of an opiate that can be
prescribed even
the patient has been controlled on a
higher dose for years with out any
evidence of addiction or overdose risks
the American Council on science in
Health believes the CDC guidelines for
primary care physicians treating chronic
non-cancer pain violates the standards
of science research in April of 17 US
News reports Maine rolls out the
nation's strictest law targeting opioid
prescriptions limiting the amount
prescribed by a physician patients say
it's harder for them to get the
prescriptions that they need so what do
we know the CDC recently reported
overdose deaths involving prescription
opioids have cried quadrupled since 1999
all cause opioid deaths continue to
climb as prescriptions become harder to
obtain it stated that one third of the
US population report to have chronic
pain which translates to approximately a
hundred million u.s. citizens it has
been reported that one in four patients
on prescription opioid treatment for
chronic non-cancer pain struggle with
addiction in a letter from the Surgeon
General to all colleagues two decades
ago urge the evaluation of pain as the
fifth vital sign
thus by elevating it to a level of
essential information like blood
pressure and heart rate he hoped that it
would be properly evaluated and managed
in the New England Journal of Medicine
back in January of 1980 this is the
letter to the editor by Porter and Jick
of the Boston collaborative drug
surveillance program based at the
University of Austin Medical Center it
is not a scientific study but it allowed
the propagation of misinformation that
was used by big pharma and incorporated
into the medical school curriculum to
drive prescribing of opioids how do we
treat the millions of Americans
suffering from chronic pain and decrease
addiction these topics are ongoing as
the death rate continues to climb it is
clear that acute pain is far different
than chronic pain and must be managed
differently on march 19th ABC News
reports that President Trump calls for
the death penalty if legally appropriate
as one solution on the attack on the
opioid epidemic this approach may have
shock value fear intimidation but
ignores the basic cause of the epidemic
and does not provide the full range of
workable solutions to deal with this
epidemic President Trump started the NIH
which stands for National Institute of
Health initiative to help end the opioid
crisis it has brought some of the most
brilliant minds to the round table
including directors of many government
agencies as well as directors of medical
institutions to work on this effort they
intend to address opioid misuse and
addiction as well as pain management
this effort is supported by current big
pharma treatment options and current
approved
medical treatment modalities ignoring
the growing body of evidence that
cannabis is an effective and safe
alternative to all of the above
treatments at the start of this
initiative the director of NIH made this
statement let me start with the revealed
wisdom that the roots of our current
opioid crisis were largely produced in
the late 1990s by the over prescribing
of opioids because of the
misunderstanding that they would not be
addictive for people with chronic pain
and that pain became the fifth vital
sign and physicians and hospitals were
guided by patients filling out surveys
on how they perceived how their
treatment of pain was being taken care
of two weeks ago I attended the American
Pharmacists Association second annual
pain Institute program held in Nashville
Tennessee to my dismay again for the
second year in a row cannabis was not
discussed in any of the presentations as
a viable treatment option not for pain
not for adjunct of pain therapy not for
opiate withdrawal in January of 2017 the
National Academy of Sciences engineering
and medicine report identified cannabis
unequivocally as a viable treatment
option for chronic pain in adults
despite the shifting nature of the
opioid epidemic government efforts to
stop it continue to focus on punishing
doctors who over prescribe in their
opinion and the pharmacist who fill the
prescriptions
the net result reducing patient access
to opioids and effective management of
their
non-cancer pain remembering the chronic
non-cancer pain is a disease one could
consider that this clamp down on
prescribing has driven patients to the
use of much more dangerous opiates and
has resulted directly in the current
climbing overdose frequency and death
rates pain patients are seeking
alternatives obeah therapy to deal with
the chronic pain and now in 29 states in
the District of Columbia cannabis is at
least at the state level accessible as
an alternative to opiates in our clinic
patients are either asking for help with
poorly managed pain or asking to get off
of opiates altogether with the use of
cannabis at our clinic we see all types
of patients that have sought cannabis as
a treatment option
I find the cannabis is one of the most
important tools I have added to my
functional medicine practice in the last
20 years I came up with the idea for
this study based on all the testimonials
and anecdotal evidence I encountered
using cannabis and standardized dosage
forms cannabis requires personalization
to optimize treatment goals it is all
about helping patients find relief
despite the challenges that this type of
study approach poses for the
interpretation of data the goals of our
study were to report on the use of
cannabis in chronic non-cancer pain
independent of use of opioids reporting
the adverse events and obtain a simple
quality of life measure from the
participant and it was simply is a
quality of your life the same better or
worse with the addition of cannabis to
your pain treatment regimen
from our clinics patient database using
December 2016 as our endpoint and
looking back the previous 12 weeks we
asked who had the diagnosis of chronic
non-cancer pain did they fit into one of
the three treatment periods were they
using opioids in their treatment regimen
did we have pre and post-treatment NES
course and what was their global rating
scale inclusion criteria included having
the diagnosis of chronic non-cancer pain
be willing to add cannabis to their pain
treatment regimen possess a valid
medical recommendation and used the
protocol developed by the PCC exclusion
criteria included diagnosis of cancer
history of an allergy to cannabis or
prescription THC products a cardiac
arrhythmia or pregnancy so we identified
81 patients with the diagnosis of
chronic non-cancer pain 70% of those
were women of those 81 patients 21 were
not evaluatable because we're missing
data they were not active or they were
too new to the program the 60 remaining
patients 18 of which were active but
they were not and placing orders but
they we did not have the data points
necessary to include them so that left
us with 42 patients who were included 15
men 27 female the average age was 61
point 7 years old and 27 were on opiates
this is an example of the trochee about
the size of a dime it's a patented
buckle delivery system that can be
caught up into quarters or even smaller
increments with uniform content
throughout the dosage form it was chosen
to maximize bioavailability and dosing
flexibility my availability is a term
used in pharmacology to describe how
much medicine you get into your system
versus how much you lose um any given
dose our clinics treatment protocol had
been developed over the previous year by
essentially trial and error our goal was
to minimize the likelihood of any
adverse event sometimes called adverse
drug reactions recognizing that over 60%
of the patients that we saw where
cannabis naive presenting to our clinic
all patients were started with a pure
CBD trochee that did not have any
detectable THC based on the patient's
response THC in various forms were
incorporated slowly into their treatment
regimen to avoid any significant
psychoactive effects our clinics
treatment protocol used standardized lab
tested medication and varying
concentrations of cannabinoids we did
not control terpene content for the
dosage forms use routes of
administration included buccal oral in
vaporization the lab that we used was
the first ISO 17025 accredited cannabis
lab in the United States that started
its work in 2012 in Murrieta California
looking at some of these examples the
is currently how cannabis medication
that has been standardized would be
labeled this is an example of a numeric
analog pain scale rating scale sometimes
called a visual analog pain rating scale
you see the scale at the bottom of the
faces from 0 to 10 anyone with chronic
pain should be aware of this type of
pain reporting scale used by their
physician to determine your pain level
in any given point in time here are the
results that in this graph we show pre
in post
nes pain scores and this shows a 68%
improvement with a p-value of 0.01 and
for those who don't know what that is
that's a statistical analysis term which
generally doesn't get any better than
that in this graph there was no
statistically significant difference in
the average changes in numeric analog
score between each treatment time period
pre and post treatment nes pain scores
showed a 68% improvement very little
difference was observed between groups
based on duration of therapy and 100% of
patients reported feeling better looking
at this pie chart in the darkest portion
which is labeled 15% had no change in
their opiate use with the addition of
cannabis to their treatment regimen and
this again is 27 patients and looking at
that data slightly differently you can
see in groups from no change in opioid
dose all the way to
um six patients that discontinued
opiates entirely with the use of
cannabis that was added to their
treatment regimen for pain one patient
even used only pure CBD no THC and was
able to get off their opiate dose the
only guidance that was used or given to
these patients was to if you don't feel
the need to reach for that bottle of
Norco or vicodin or oxycodone don't wait
until you feel the need to take your
next dose so key takeaways we saw 68
percent reduction in pain score with all
participants reporting some degree of
improvement various concentrations of
oral mucosal THC and CBD were used alone
or in combination with oral THC AAA with
similar results THC a a is the acid form
of THC which is typically the neutral
form of the cannabinoid that causes the
most psychoactive effect eighty five
point two percent of participants taking
opioid medication reduced or
discontinued it and none withdrew from
the study due to intolerable side
effects
so in conclusion our observational
longitudinal study all participants
experienced an improvement in their post
treatment nes score with our with or
without opioids our results support
other published reports indicating a 25
to 100 percent reduction in the use of
opiates
when cannabis is included in pain
management regiments the use of cannabis
did not cause adverse events that force
discontinuance and all patients noted a
global improvement in their quality of
life with the use of cannabis contrary
to news reports or Medical Association
opinion there is a lot of data
supporting the use of cannabis and the
treatment of pain here Lynch in 2015 it
is a systematic review of the randomized
controlled trials that it would have
been published examining cannabinoids in
the treatment of chronic non-cancer pain
their results looking at 11 trials seven
of the trials demonstrated significant
analgesic effects and adverse events
were mild to moderate and severity which
generally included fatigue or dizziness
and were well tolerated this review adds
further support that currently available
cannabinoids are safe modestly effective
analgesics that provide a reasonable
therapeutic option in the management of
chronic non-cancer pain McCollum and
Rousseau published a paper in March of
2018 discussing some of the practical
considerations why cannabis has left
physicians in the dark as how to advise
patients pursuing such treatment this
report demonstrates there is guidance in
peer-reviewed published data for
prescribers to look to for helping their
patients consider cannabis is an option
for treating chronic pain in the red
highlighted area with the advent
pharmaceutical cannabis based medicines
and they include Sativex an epidural axe
two brand-name products from GW Pharma
and liberalization of access in certain
nations this ignorance of cannabis
pharmacology and therapeutics has become
untenable the primary reason is due to
our federal government's continued
refusal to acknowledge the medical
benefits of cannabis and take cannabis
off schedule 1 drug classification in
March 2018 eshwara
published a perspective study that
included twenty seven hundred and thirty
six patients all above 65 years of age
who received medical cannabis from
January 2015
till October 2017 in a specialized
medical cannabis clinic and were willing
to answer the initial questionnaire
outcomes of the study were pain
intensity quality of life and adverse
events at six months of treatment time
after the six months of treatment ninety
three point seven percent of the
respondents reported improvement in
their condition and the reported pain
level was reduced from a median of eight
out of ten to a median of four this is
consistent with my studies observation
in conclusion they find our study finds
that therapeutic use of cannabis is safe
and efficacious in the elderly
population cannabis use may decrease the
use of other prescription medicines
including opioids
in June 2017 rhymin published a study
out of UC Berkeley to examine and study
the use of cannabis as a substitute for
opioid based pain medication
hello md's patients were sent a survey
and that was sent to sixty-seven
thousand four hundred and twenty two
patients of the sixty seven thousand
plus patients twenty eight hundred and
ninety seven responded of those
respondents thirty-four percent reported
the use of opioid based medications in
the last six months
respondents overwhelmingly reported the
cannabis provided relief on par with
their other medications but without the
unwanted side-effects so in their
questionnaire they listed strongly
agreed or agreed and ninety seven
percent of the respondents said that
they strongly agreed or agreed that they
can decrease opioids with the
concomitant use of cannabis use
eighty-one percent strongly agreed or
agreed the cannabis alone was more
effective than the combination and
ninety two percent strongly agreed or
agreed that they preferred cannabis to
opiates ethan russo provided data
supporting phase one through phase three
clinical studies on GW Pharma Sativex a
commercial cannabis one-to-one ratio CBD
to THC extract available in 27 countries
on prescription since 2007 it was clear
that the use of a whole plant extract
worked in 2000 subjects with 1000
patient years of exposure over four
years for neuropathic pain and sleep
neuropathic pain is a type of chronic
non-cancer pain that is very hard to
treat and does not respond well to
opiate therapy how can our FDA ignore
the fact that equivalent organizations
to them from around the world have
evaluated the data and approved cannabis
for the medical treatment in their
respective countries besides the
overabundance of published literature
indicating the cannabis is helpful for
chronic pain and has a synergistic
effect in combination with opiates and
other pain medication there is
epidemiologic support that supports cost
savings in the healthcare system
in July of 2016
bradford using data on all prescriptions
filled by Medicare Part D enrollees from
2010 to 2013 found that the use of
prescription drugs for which marijuana
could serve as a clinical alternative
fell significantly once medical
marijuana laws were implemented in that
state and I quote we found that the use
of prescription drugs for which
marijuana could serve as a clinical
alternative fell significantly once a
medical marijuana marijuana law was
implemented powell
reports in the journal of health
economics March of this year recent work
finds that medical marijuana laws
reduced the daily doses filled for
opioid analgesics
Medicare Part D in Medicaid in royal
enrollees as well as population wide
opioid overdose deaths in one study
there was a twenty four point six
percent reduction in the overdose death
in states that had access to medical
marijuana as states become more as
states have become more stringent in
their regulation of dispensaries the
protective value generally has fallen
these findings suggest that broader
access to medical marijuana facilitates
substitution of marijuana for more
powerful and addictive opioids cannabis
what is a good starting dose most
patients naive the cannabis should start
or begin at a 2.5 milligram dose of the
neutral form of THC with CBD or taking
CBD alone and then adding THC to their
treatment regimen generally starting at
least three days later taking it at
night there's a slogan that should never
be forgotten by anyone stepping into the
cannabis arena and that is you always
start the dose low and you go up slow
everyone has their own unique response
to cannabis and the cannabis ratios that
are used in well-built products you need
to find out what that is for you and
even though there's average assumptions
that staff at dispensaries or
prescribers can make its
still is very individualized medicine
different delivery methods have
different on sets of action and
durations of action so be cautious and
pay attention to the ratios of CBD and
THC and other cannabinoids and
terpenoids now there's different ways to
consume medical cannabis combustion or
smoking the flower the a pipe a
vaporizer or a joint is still the most
common route of administration for
consuming cannabis
although combusting plant material is
generally not recognized is the safest
route of administration for consuming
cannabis vaporization is much better for
an inhalation route and that can include
both flower and concentrates edible
forms of cannabis are generally
considered food deserts candy type
products pharmaceutical dosage forms
would be capsules again taken by the
oral route or tablets tinctures the
trokey that was described in one study
presented to you solutions and
sublingual tablets these can either be
sublingual which means under your tongue
or buckle between cheek and gum
there's topical routes using transdermal
patches creams and ointments transdermal
patches can be used for direct over the
pain locations or they can be placed in
areas to do
liver a systemic dose of the
cannabinoids contained in those patches
typically creams and ointments give very
little systemic absorption and they're
used locally for the area of pain that a
patient is experiencing suppositories is
another pharmaceutical route of
administration and this is a very
interesting route because on any given
dose of the neutral form of THC the
psychoactive component of cannabis or
whether it's an extractor or what you
generally get only about a 30%
equivalent effect of the psychoactive
effect that you would get if you took it
orally so all of these different routes
of administration will have different on
sets of action in durations of action
and depending on the dosage you take
those can be very impactful on the
duration of action so in summary there
is unequivocal evidence published in the
literature that cannabis is safe and
effective for the treatment of chronic
pain in adults cannabis has been shown
to reduce and or replace the use of
opioids in the treatment of all types of
chronic pain conditions state
legalization of cannabis has
demonstrated a reduction in the use of
pharmaceuticals in the treatment of pain
in other conditions states that have
legalized cannabis for medical use show
a decrease in the overdose death rates
cannabis has shown to be safe a loner in
combination with opiates and its use
does not cause harmful adverse events
from its appropriate use
there is an opiate epidemic in the u.s.
in current treatments did not offer
cannabis as a component to the treatment
options our federal government refuses
to base policy on science regarding
cannabis use in healthcare apparently
clearly protecting special interests
state governments and the people
continue to expand the use of cannabis
state-by-state either by vote or by
direct legislative action and as long as
cannabis or marijuana is held hostage as
a Schedule one substance research will
be limited access will be limited and
the incorporation of its use in medicine
within the US will be oppressed take
action your voice counts I'd like to
leave you with a video I've seen many
testimonials from parents patients and
practitioners on how cannabis is touched
and changed lives in a positive way this
mother of a beautiful 13 year old
daughter wanted to specifically send a
message to all of you let's hear what
she has to say
I thank you for having me today I'm a
stay home mom to four wonderful kids and
my husband as a full-time homicide
detective in 2008 my daughter was
diagnosed with stage 3 kidney cancer and
had to go through chemotherapy and
radiation and I'm proud to say today
that she is a cancer survivor
unfortunately in the same year my
daughter was also diagnosed with the rsd
it's a rare nervous condition that has
no cure it leaves the patient in great
deal amount of pain and medications have
done nothing to provide her any relief
we've tried physical therapy acupuncture
chiropractic swimming oils heat lamps
pain pads the list goes on and on I
started my research after we stopped all
medications due to the severe side
effects and found a link about cannabis
I contacted dr. Kent and realized that I
would like to try to start the trokey he
started the trophy in January and after
the first week she no longer had any
pain after the second week she was
sleeping much better I told dr. Kent how
wonderful the medication was working for
her she's maintained on the principles
list at school starting to interact with
her peers and is overall very happy I
would like you to know that cannabis the
medicine has done wonders for my child
and I'm hoping that in the future more
children will be exposed to this
wonderful medicine
I hope my hope is that you keep an open
mind and do the research on cannabis
thank you
Thank You dr. Crowley for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question we'd like
to ask please do so now just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question and then click the
send up well answer as many questions as
we have time for let's get started our
first question is what does buggle
administration me buckle administration
is the placement within the mouth when
we're looking for oral mucosal
absorption so what that means is buccal
is between cheek and gum it can be on
the upper part or down in the lower part
and that's distinctly different than
placement of sublingual or under the
tongue so many tinctures solutions
sublingual tablets those will be placed
under the tongue they're held in the
mouth preferably for a minimum of five
minutes before swallowing but if you
could last for 15 that would optimize
the amount of that medication that gets
absorbed through the oral mucosa and the
purpose of that is so that we limit the
variables that are associated with you
know swallowing and then the gut
function when something goes down the
hatch all of that absorption and blood
flow goes directly to the liver and that
is called first pass metabolism when
that blood from the GI tract goes to the
liver and works on those actives when we
use the oral mucosal route of
administration that bypasses first pass
metabolism and it optimizes the
bioavailability or how much
that active dose of medication gets into
your system versus how much you lose it
also allows for more reproducible
results of a given cannabis dosage form
buckle in particular with the trokey
delivery system is designed to slow down
the dissolution of that dosage form so
by slowing down dissolution and by
decreasing the amount of saliva that you
ultimately will swallow that improves
even more that active dose that you've
taken of cannabis in that delivery
system to get into your system and
increases by availability so placement
between cheek and gum to minimize the
amount of saliva produced is generally
on your upper cheek and gum under your
upper lip great our next question is can
taking cannabis along with opiate
medication cause an overdose no and how
can I make that definitive statement
it's because cannabis receptors in the
central nervous system are not involved
with the respiratory depression areas of
the brain that mu or opiate receptors
are involved with so the combination of
adding cannabis to an opiate will not
increase the likelihood of respiratory
depression but it will substantially
increase the effectiveness of opiates
when in combination with
Annabeth's and some studies report as
much at least in the animal model a 3.6
fold improvement in the effectiveness of
any given opioid dose with the addition
of cannabis okay we have time for one
more question
is there any difference and the effects
of cannabis based on the route of
administration substantial if we look at
the inhalation route the onset of action
is under a minute he could generally
five minutes and duration of action one
to two hours if we look at an edible a
food product and we eat that edible
product depending on what's in your
stomach and the type of food that you
ate whether it was a brownie or a cookie
something with more fat involved in it
versus a piece of candy or it's some
type of dessert the onset of action
typically is described as one to two
hours for an onset and then the duration
is between you know four hours to well
over 24 hours depending on the dose that
someone takes tinctures solutions things
that are administered sublingual those
typically have a 15 to 30 minute onset
of action and a duration of 3 to 4 hours
the trokey fits uniquely into a very
broad spot between all these other
routes of administration because the
onset of action I taken correctly which
is
buckle II under the upper lip and gum
has a five-minute onset of action and a
duration similar to an edible based on
the dose that you took I would like to
once again thanks dr. Crowley for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for an on-demand
viewing to June 2018 you will receive an
email from laggards letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues dimittimus today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining this you hope to see you
again soon goodbye